[Music]
Jennifer is here Jennifer's University
of Virginia Media Studies and currently
is at the Center for Advanced Study in
the behavioral sciences at Stanford
we've got some brochures from casbahs in
the back we have really enjoyed the a
wide range of great academics on a broad
range of social sciences that from
casbahs have spoken for us over the
years and tonight is another great
addition to that series so definitely
take a look and find out more about
casbahs because they have their own
speaking series and and I highly
recommend that you may have noticed as
you came in we have a single copy of
Jennifer's book so it's a collector's
edition yes price is gonna get higher
all night David earthquake Day 2017 so
and it's also available on Kindle I'm
led to believe so just just so you know
on that front and I just want to say a
quick thanks I think she'll mention in
her talk as well we want to say thank
you to Rick Prelinger and the Prelinger
archives who helped us source a couple
of the films that you saw I hope you
enjoyed the silent film show at the
starts now without any further ado
please give a big round of applause will
bring Jennifer this day
thank you guys and thanks to everyone
for coming out tonight I'm gonna tonight
give you a bit of a media history of
free speech and hopefully and if the
focus is gonna be on the early 20th
century but hopefully this will be a
useful or at least entertaining context
for thinking about some of the big
questions that we're facing today with
new technologies like you know computer
programs and outputs of algorithms and
whether or not these things can be
considered speech so in the United
States any history of free speech begins
in 1789
with the First Amendment of the
Constitution and which we've got into
formats up here so in this little phrase
the Congress shall make no law abridging
the freedom of speech or the press is
seems simple enough but it's highly
contentious but most broadly we can say
or this is how we've interpreted it is
to say that the government can't make up
any laws restricting the sharing or
publication of ideas we can make of all
kinds of laws restricting what we can do
our actions or our conduct our behavior
but not what we say so for example
congressman government can make laws
saying you know you have to stop at a
stoplight that's something we consider
reasonable but they can't say you can't
critique the stoplight or the police
officer or the law okay so this is what
it's come to mean so what I'm as a media
historian I'm more interested here in
the understanding of what is expressive
than the history of the freedoms so I'm
interested in what objects texts and
even actions lawyers and justices have
come to see as expressive and why now
this question was pretty easy for those
who wrote this in 1789 the primary
vehicles for publication were the human
voice in the printing press so the
objects covered by it were pretty
straightforward too but since this and
especially in the 20th century things
have gotten more complicated and the
question of what counts as speech has
become a really interesting one
and my basic argument is that the way
that justices have answered this
question has a lot to do with their
experience with communication and
communications media as well as the
whatever ideas are circulating about
communication at the time so what I'm
going to do today is tell a little bit
of an intellectual history of free
speech and for any lawyers in the room
it'll be a strange history of free
speech I'm gonna talk to tal you back to
a moment when when something we probably
all think of as expressive film was
considered not to be speech for the law
and I'm gonna flesh out why and explain
what ideas of communication made this
made sense and then talk about how and
when this changed which was in the 1940s
and here we move from cases dealing with
film to ones dealing with flag stories
and then end with a few questions about
what parallels there might be if any
between these issues and those were
facing today so here we go in 1915 the
Supreme Court decided that movies were
not part of the freedom of speech or the
press and before I go any further I need
to tell you a couple of things so first
off in 1915 freedom of speech was not
the same as today it was not as free as
today so there just wasn't that much in
the way of free speech legal cases and
when these cases were heard the courts
weren't all that generous or all that
friendly so for example during World War
one the Supreme Court said it was
perfectly fine to throw dissidents in
jail this was not a violation of the
First Amendment so we're talking about a
really different legal environment one
where freedom of speech is not the same
as it is today the second thing is that
films were not the same as they are
today so Hollywood was not yet an
industry really films were still in
formation there were many different
types of motion pictures as they were
called at the time that were considered
that were lumped together in the very
earliest films or motion pictures
moving images this is where movies come
from there's a lot of emphasis on the
ability of them to capture human and
mechanical movement the earliest these
were called actualities and they showed
they were silent and they were often
only a few minutes long and they often
showed images of everyday life so again
the focus is on the ability of the
technology to capture and reproduce this
and you would see street scenes scenes
of factories trains subways things like
this where sometimes things we might
think of as current events like for
example the earthquake film that you saw
that was taken about 110 years ago today
or tomorrow that was you know
chronicling what happened after the
earthquake in San Francisco by the teens
filmmakers were experimenting with story
films they used editing acting and you
notice this acting is very melodramatic
it's uses a lot of gesture to tell the
story and intertitles as well to tell a
story these were still pretty short
generally less than 30 minutes long and
some of these were really kind of pure
fun they were the types of you know
comedies in the in Charlie Chaplin films
this is a very beginning of Charlie
Chaplin's career others were attempting
to educate or instill a moral lesson so
for example here we're seeing in the
spirit of the flag film about patriotism
and the need to sacrifice for one's
nation and we're seeing you write a
story about how to be a good man how you
know this is a nice white kind of
colonial guy is defending the native
Filipina is honor from this CAD so we've
got this kind of like moral lesson going
on there were also films there are a
number of films yeah and patronising yes
so you would also have temperance films
films trying to you know teach young
immigrant girls about the you know evils
of prostitution and such things these
films were quite popular there are
reports that 26 million people were
going to go see films every and every
week and this was about this is a third
of the population or almost a third of
the population at a time so this is an
incredibly popular pastime and a number
of the people who are going to go see
these films are children and immigrants
or at least that's what people talked
about and thought and for politicians
and activists of the day children and
immigrants are too particularly
vulnerable populations or groups of
people that need to be protected from
things like potentially films that might
have immoral influences and one of the
ways that reformers and politicians try
to do this is through censoring films
deciding what films are good only
letting the films that might be good and
useful through to these audiences and in
1911 three states following six
suggestions start established laws that
establish censor board's the three
states are Pennsylvania Kansas and Ohio
many more states would follow but these
are the first three and so these laws
said that any every film had to be
pre-screened by a censor board before it
could be shown within that state and so
these censor board's would be generally
citizens who would watch every movie who
decide this one can be shown this one
can't if it could be shown it got a seal
of approval this would be at the
beginning or at the end of the film and
if you're watching a film and it didn't
have this that was an illegal and
illicit film so this in for film
distributors this was not a popular
thing if this really mucked up the
business you can't ship off the same
films to Ohio as you can to Tennessee
right these sensor boards really and
they have to wait for them to be
screened and there's all kinds of things
that just get in the way
and so in 1913 one of these distributors
Mutual films sues the state of Ohio and
says this censor board you've got here
is a violation of free speech and now to
be clear right they're not really
necessarily thinking about anybody's
civil liberties here they're thinking
about their business interests and
making this claim in this way so this is
a venerable tradition goes back at least
to 1913 and so they they say this is a
this is a violation of freedom of speech
and it went all the way up to the
Supreme Court and in a unanimous
decision in 1915 the court said well no
movies are not speech they're not
protected by the First Amendment or by
freedom of speech law and the reasons
that gave weren't the ones that we might
suspect they didn't say that films
weren't protected under freedom of
speech because they were mere
entertainment or because they weren't
really political or because you know
they didn't give us anything useful and
actually they explicitly acknowledged
all these things they said yeah films
are educational they're useful and
indeed they convey ideas their mediums
have thought but still they're not
speech the reason was the type of
communication they conveyed ideas they
conveyed them the way they did that's it
did circuses theater and show other
shows and spectacles all things that we
would want to regulate so what they had
to say about this mode of communication
was several different things first off
they had to say it was crass
commercialism second that there were
mere representations of events right
they were either adaptations of books or
it was just capturing events like the
aftermath of the earthquake and
reproducing them on the screen didn't
publicize anything or add anything new
to the conversation or that they were a
really different type of communication
they were closer to physical action or
conduct then to speech or the conveyance
of ideas
now this last one probably seems pretty
strange to most of us in this room and
so I want to turn to another similar
case or related case where the justices
flush this out what they mean by this
they say some similar things and flush
it out
and in this case seven years later it's
closely related but what we have here is
actually a newsreel so New York State
censors censored a newsreel that had an
image of a woman in a bathing suit this
is not the woman this is not the from
the film but this is what the bathing
suit would look like is obviously very
scandalous and the distributor said well
wait a minute
this is the news you shouldn't be
pre-screening and censoring newsreels
this is a clear violation of freedom of
the press and they took this to the
court and this one didn't go to the
Supreme Court just to the New York State
courts the New York State Appellate
Court disagreed they said no this is not
a violation of freedom of the press it's
not as we might think in this room right
the news that's privileged by freedom of
the press or of speech but it's not the
ideas not the contour not the content of
the information conveyed but the manner
that it's conveyed they said this speech
here this freedom doesn't cover
everything it doesn't cover just news it
covers expression of thought involving
conscious mental effort not mere action
okay so the suggestion is these films
are mere action in contrast to this type
of mental activity like the formation of
judgment opinions etc the judges said
current events films and other films
might convey ideas but they did so
differently than newspapers in film for
the audience no mental activity is
required all the audience is doing is
absorbing ideas or ideas are being
implanted in them
the judge said there's not a speaker
written film there is no speaker merely
an actor or a body performing ideas and
for the audience the physical experience
of spectacle
and spectacle right a turn of the turn
of the century doesn't merely mean
something that you look at but it means
something you've experienced a kind of a
visceral physical way
so films might be spectacles butts or
rollercoasters and I don't mean looking
at them going on the roller coaster so
this is a type of experience they're
talking about so in summary you know
films aren't speech because they're
imitative because they use images and
gestures to convey ideas rather than
words and because they worked on the
bodies rather than the minds of the
audiences and this again seems strange
to us but at the time it made total
sense it fit perfectly within the way
that academics specifically social
psychologists sociologists were talking
about communication in the early 20th
century and many politicians to building
upon this work so these academics and
politicians in early 20th century talked
about there being two distinct modes of
communication and these distinct modes
of communication mapped to different
classes of people the first was the
irrational communication of crowds and
the second is the kind of reasoned
deliberation of public opinion and that
was something that was done by the
middle and upper classes so and when
they talk about the way the justices are
talking about film echoes and borrows a
lot from the way that academics and
politicians are talking about crowds
these people thought that crowds
communicated without mental activity or
without reflection through imitation and
through suggestion which isn't fully
rational and people in crowds responded
to simple ideas and emotions they saw
around them so in crowds needed a leader
this leader might be a speaker or an
actor because theaters were hot beds of
crowd activity very disreputable places
and so there might be a leader but and
people are responding to the the words
but also to the manner in which they're
being spoken the manner in which they're
being communicated
they're getting images or they're
getting absorbing emotions from looking
at the bodily pose or the bodily
gestures and the facial expressions of
the speaker and those around them so
this is very emotional form of
communication and it's very imitative
you know people are looking and seeing
the way other people feel and taking
that on themselves almost as a sort of
reflex this is a very different way than
we think
like there's no psychological processing
it's a very reflexive response now this
was bad for a couple of reasons first
off everyone in the crowd is responding
to the same thing they're all looking at
and responding and taking on the same
feelings and these are embodied and so
they're all potentially being excited by
the same things in the same direction
they all might start to act together
become disorderly disrupt the streets
pick up a rock and throw it to your
window right and the people were
thinking about this other people who
owned the windows right this is an elite
fair crowds were always on the verge of
turning into dangerous mobs and this is
what you know general strike might look
like now the second type of
communication that people talked about
at the time was the total opposite of
this it was public opinion which did you
know people public opinion it
encompassed everything that was the
opposite of crowd psychology
it was reason deliberation expression of
an individual opinion and dispassionate
judgment and in conversations among
again academics and politicians the
newspaper was a really important part of
this the newspaper was closely
associated with public opinion it was a
way that the newspaper brought people
together in mind mentally but not
physically so people are reading the
news and connecting through reading the
same ideas thinking about the same
things and then discussing them in small
groups
in this for elites in the early
twentieth century this is what democracy
looks like this is democratic
communication it's the good stuff and
this is what the justices are thinking
about when they're thinking about what
speech is on a number of levels this
type of activity or mental activity not
activity but also probably the types of
people involved as well okay um so film
just doesn't fit this picture film is a
primitive communication the fact that it
uses images and gestures and excites the
bodies of his audiences means that we
can't consider it part of what speech is
so so that's how people are talking and
thinking about speech circa 1920 in
19-point 1943 all of this has changed
and the law the place where this changes
is or the moment where it changes is
1943 where the justices again think
about images gestures and primitive
communication but at this moment they
come to a really different set of
conclusions they say that images and
gestures can speak and they are part of
the speech protected a part of our First
Amendment rights because they are
primitive so let me step this out and
I'll step this out a little bit in a
minute and it happens in a case you know
that doesn't have anything to do with
films but rather with flag salute in the
case is West Virginia Board of Education
versus Barnette and the policy at issue
here is West Virginia policy that
requires every student to salute the
flag and in the late 30s right in the
run-up to the u.s. entry into World War
two a number of states were passing
these kinds of laws forcing children to
salute the flag in order to instill
patriotism national unity etc Jehovah's
Witnesses objected they said the flag is
an image and that we are being forced to
break the second commandment by
worshipping a graven image
so the Jobos witnesses sued and there
are a number of legal cases the most
consequential one is West Virginia Board
of Education versus Barnette it was an
expansive case what we would think of
today as judicial activism in which the
court said that the flag and the gesture
were uh pterence --is akin to speech by
forcing these Jehovah's Witnesses to do
the salute you're forcing them to say
something say something they might not
believe in and that is compelled speech
which is an abridgment of First
Amendment so again we have images the
flag and the physical gesture okay this
time they're being included within the
law
now it's worth taking time to note that
the specific that this West Virginia
Board of Education policy required a
very specific gesture the flag salute
that was originally written into the law
was the Bellamy salute which was a
common salute in the United States from
the late 19th century to the 30s that
you see here arm outstretched now by the
end of the late 30s this salute had
taken on a different set of meanings and
connotations and it was in this context
most people would have seen these images
they would have seen photographs or
newsreels of the Berlin games of Nazi
rallies so this would have been one of
the things in people's minds when
they're thinking about this salute and
with this in mind this is this the set
of contra kind of uncomfortable
connotations helps to highlight the ways
in which this gesture was expressive and
the different things it might speak and
it also I want to it also you know if
you think about you know you're a parent
and you're thinking about your child's
being forced to you know engage in this
salute your child is being forced to
kind of act in a way that you associate
with the Hitler Youth this is not an you
know not an abstract thing this is a
very emotional deep-seated political
kind of response it might have a set of
feelings that this that this flag salute
was evoke and this emotionality in 1943
was part of was it was a good thing in
the sense that it was part of what made
this expression under the law it was
part of what made its speech so there's
a pretty strong contrast between the way
that the justices are reasoning and
thinking about what speech is in 1943
then in 1915
and 22 their reasons as to why this is
speech really focused on the power of
symbols and by symbols here they mean
images and gestures their ability to
evoke simple ideas and emotions without
all the lengthy reason giving and
explanation of words and so some of the
very things that had made film seem
outside of speech something that we
didn't want to include within this
category now become reasons for
including these images and gestures
within it so this is total rewriting or
and expansion of what speech means so
what happened in order to enable this
the quick and dirty the easiest way to
answer this is Americans discovered
Freud and the subconscious from Freud we
learned that we were all driven by
unconscious drives and thoughts none of
us were pure you know we're masters of
our own minds and that we were none of
us were purely rational but we also
learned that this irrationality was a
product of our minds not our bodies so
the subconscious right is source of
irrationality it's a psychological
process it's something that makes us
uniquely human whereas in the 20s and
15s the source of irrationality is the
body and it's something that is shared
among humans primitives and animals so
this is a really different way of
thinking about a rationale 'ti in the
many different forms of persuasion that
were common at the time that people were
experiencing from propaganda to ads
which were considered commercial
propaganda underscore at this point by
the late 20s and 30s such appeals were
understood and critiqued people began to
think of propaganda as a bad thing in
the late 20s where they hadn't before in
terms of manipulation and as a
particularly cycle
logical and emotional form of
manipulation and there's a bit of an
interesting history here around this
World War one poster if you want to ask
about it later it's a little beside the
point now hey so these things this
experience of propaganda and the
psychological frameworks taught us that
we were all or taught people that they
were all subject to manipulation and
that this manipulation was a mental or
psychological process in this we have a
real shift in the way that public
opinion is understood with this way of
understanding propaganda psychology
persuasion we really see this a shift in
the way people talk about public opinion
whereas in 1915 public opinion is
associated with rationality deliberation
at this point you know nobody's fully
rational public opinion can't be purely
rational and in public opinion
increasingly is understood as a mix of
rational and irrational mental processes
and has talked about public opinion it
becomes interchangeable with attitudes
which is a much more psychological term
and along with this we have a shift in
the types of or the fears associated
with communications the problems that we
might have with it we're no longer
worried about the masses and the kind of
physical influence or physical
disruptions of the masses by 1943 were
worried about the mass okay and the idea
and also about psychological influence
and manipulation and homogenization so
this is the public or the mass that the
justices in the Barnett decision are
thinking about everyone is part of this
there's not a big distance between
elites and workers here everyone's part
of the same audience is subject to the
same persuasion the same psychological
manipulation and this is a public that's
already awash in images
actions communication via image and
actions and so the justices in Barnet
decide that images and gestures or
actions can speak just at a moment where
public opinion is understood to be more
emotive and just at a moment where they
consider themselves of more primitive
people as well or in closer proximity to
everyone else there is no longer a big
separation between elites and the masses
everyone's engaging in the same thing
and indeed at the time one of the
justices in the case moans this fact in
a dissent he says we all live by symbols
this is inescapable so the justices here
understand themselves as well to be
susceptible this is what it is this is a
state of public opinion if public
opinion is emotional than emotional
communication by an image and gesture is
part and parcel this is part of our
speech so the law changed because the
communicative experiences of the
justices and because of the way people
were talking about communication so what
can we learn about this for today well
in the early 20th century legal
discussions about what speech is and
what it's not centered on what separated
civilized human beings from less
civilized human beings and in this case
bodies were central they kind of marked
the the outer limits of what could be
speech now today they don't we consider
many embodied actions to be expressive
to be part of speech from silent
protests to make a dancing and
flag-burning these all might be
considered expressive they're no longer
outside speech today rather it's a
different set of things that we think
about when we think about the limit
cases of speech or what might be the
ends of speech discussions around
machine actions and automation are often
the big question marks can these things
be considered part of speech something
that's protected or covered by the First
Amendment
today currently courts are facing or
will face very interesting sets of
questions about whether or not human
communication to computers or computer
communication to humans can be
considered speech questions like is
computer code especially code written in
machine readable language ones and zeros
speech or is it merely machine action
okay
one of these is potentially protected in
some way the other one not work is it at
this point it could be a little bit of
both and to use a set of or to kind of
explain this or give the set of legal
analogies that have been used is this
more like a blueprint pure ideas or is
this code like blueprint and assembly
all rolled into one similarly are the
outputs of algorithms which are the
products of both human programmers
machine and and judgments machine
processing and often a lot of other
sources of information things often
information supplied by bunches of
different users online especially if
we're thinking about recommendation
engines are these speech are they and if
so who's and this is one of the sets of
recommendations are you know computer
aids I'm always looking using okay and
similarly or what about Twitter BOTS or
a eyes and I have here a picture of Tay
do you guys all know I'm thinking people
know the story of Tay okay so are these
types of automated intelligence or
artificial intelligences speech whose in
the case of Tay you know one of the
questions we get to is who's responsible
for tase if taya libel somebody say
who's responsible so I want to end by
with the question of where are we at and
how should we be answering these
questions and I want to really hopefully
draw on the wisdom of the room and
thinking about this and also so these
specific
about human-computer communication but
also a little bit more in a little bit
more of a meta way what are the limits
how are we answering these questions
today and what can what are the
considerations that are shaping the way
we answer them and what are the limit
cases for how we think and talk about
what speech is okay thank you Thank You
Jennifer
so as Jennifer said we'd love for this
to turn into more of kind of a
discussion within the room so if you I'm
sure we have a lot of people in
technology here we probably have some
folks that are in the law here we
probably have some of you were just
curious or or concerned have or
something that you've seen here so we've
got two microphones that are gonna be
that's Rio and Rosanna who have the mics
let them know if you've got a question
they'll both be going around the room
I'm gonna sneak in the first one here
and and again this is open if you've got
a response to it in the room as well and
and I should say the folks on the
livestream please chime in as well we'd
love to have you talking to so one of
the most striking things I think
probably for a lot of folks here is that
pronunciation of re presentations in
those early days and it strikes me that
in the data model in a lot of ways
there's a different kind of
representation and algorithmic you know
iteration of very variations of those
presentation of facts or of not facts
that are already out there are there
thoughts about that or and and maybe
maybe just say something again about
that representation and does that apply
in something here too
well this issue of representation and
copies is really I don't think we're as
worried about it anymore and obviously
the status of the copy is very different
once you get to computers the digital
copy and the distance between the
digital copy and the original is closer
I think then people then people were
thinking about the relationship of a
copy in the original and early 20th
century interestingly this idea of
certain forms of mediation being mere
copies was taken up and used later on
and not very successfully in the 1930s
in one of the first attempts to regulate
radio one of their fences was one of in
a challenge to the FCC about radio
regulation the FCC said well radio isn't
really speech because it's merely the
reproduction of human speech at the
other end so the voice you're hearing
isn't really the voice it's a mere copy
so they made this argument and they're
probably looking here to this case into
some other cases and trying to use this
argument it didn't fly in the 30s so I
think you know there's kind of a change
in the worry about copies that it Peaks
actually probably around the 30s and 40s
and then recedes there's a lot of stuff
about music and canned music versus live
music which is part of this so you've
been a good audience you've been
absorbing ideas have thoughts on on any
of the anything you've heard tonight
really but and just like no there we've
got our first question here so this last
question actually touches on what you
were just discussing so I could imagine
interpreting sort of a bot anywhere from
its mere reproduction the author of the
algorithm created it it's merely
reproduced like radio and to the other
extreme which is you can even go back to
a movie or a product or a performance
and say well if you author had an intent
but the actor added value so the
question is and if you go back pre bot
if an actor or a presenter were to
present some other
producers work who's held accountable
for the free speech the performer or the
author okay let me try and parse that in
so if we're thinking about where do the
ideas or who's speaking in that case
right if we're thinking about a
performance at this point we would
probably maybe think that the auth that
the performer is speaking in some way
not in 1950 probably not in 1960s this
is a really recent way of a lots
responsible yeah potentially which is
kind of blows your mind and it's
problematic in a number of ways but this
is with the the performance the human
performer and I think there's a number
of differences probably in a question
about BOTS and and we were talking
earlier before the show that in the
silent film days mm-hmm
the actors weren't recognized so there's
there's an ass but there's there's media
here there's technology and there's also
culture right so yes culture you know it
may be that culture comes to recognize a
bot or an AI as an author as an agent in
a way that right now we see it as a
machine in the same way that the actors
were not recognized or the directors per
se yes and there's early silent movies
right because that was yet yeah that's
great
that's another over here would start
there and we have um hi yeah you talked
about the the transition between crowd
and spectacle to then the understanding
of propaganda later on and I was just
thinking of the earlier films like I
mean a Brisbane nation for example and
that film seemed to understand its
nature as propaganda so I'm wondering if
there was a disparity between the way
they filmmakers thought of what they
were doing and then the way it was
perceived that is a great question I'm
so glad you asked that question
actually I flipped my
so yeah probably there is a disparity
and in fact yeah
Griffith writes treatise about this like
this is my speech how can you trample on
it these are ideas so yeah there's a
disparity between the just the way the
justices are thinking about film and the
way at least some of the film producers
are thinking about it but probably film
producers are thinking a lot of
different ways about film I had here a
poster advertising Birth of a Nation in
1915 and it's advertised as the world's
biggest spectacle that it has something
about how many thousands of people were
used to make the film but also the film
was clearly understood to be political
it instigated riots you know some people
argue that this was formative in the
creation of the ACLU and we know that
the Chief Justice of the Supreme Court
went and watched Birth of a Nation I
think two weeks before releasing this
opinion so and he watched at the Press
Club not at a theatre so it would have
been a slightly different experience but
he would have been aware this is being
shown at the Press Club this is clearly
being a you know just positioned as a
political statement and so they were
they were aware of film is propaganda in
this way it's that it's propagandizing
in a way that we can't defend against in
a way I think is the best way of
explaining it it's telling us these
ideas but in a way that our bodies
respond to and our mind doesn't have
time to sit back reflect in formats and
responses and and and maybe part of that
also you know there's there's the famous
to Train film one of the first people
have a physical response because they
haven't mm-hmm dealt with as much it was
interesting in the early case that you
cited that they recognized the
educational aspect of it they certainly
recognized the intent mm-hmm that was
coming at it but yeah
another question right here so yeah your
so Jennifer as you went into this we
live in a system of you know
constitutional founded country the
British don't have a constitution we
have a common law system so in common
law we look at precedents and we look at
intent of the law so as you began this
look did you go actually behind the
First Amendment look at all the the
partial writings which I am NOT a
scholar but I know they're fairly
limited okay but there are some there is
some literature at the time that
informed the people who wrote it did you
look at that and did you make a judgment
about intent and if you did what's your
reasoning that you concluded about the
intent of it versus what the questions
you raised here and excuse me are you
talking about the First Amendment itself
or about the mutual decisions these
specific decisions the linkage I'm
making is that there is an intent behind
the First Amendment and therefore that
intent informs us so they they might say
we've written the words that say it's
human speech we assume this context but
there's other philosophy there's other
writings behind it that you could read
you could say well the intent means that
whatever the future expression is that's
fine we intend there to be a dialogue
discourse and we don't care about the
medium no well when I'm not talking I'm
not spending a lot of time debating the
meaning the original intent I kind of
that's inaccessible from my perspective
my theoretical perspective and
disciplinary perspective that that's
lost we'll never know that this was
written by committee they disagreed
about what they had to say what they
meant in a sense so the the first
amendment I don't think personally I
don't think looking for an intent behind
that is particularly actually I don't
think it's possible as kind of a you
know the type of scholar that I am I
wouldn't look to that more broadly in
thinking of in my method of approach I'm
not focusing on what these justices
think and what they're with the intents
of these different justices
either I'm interested in the arguments
that they're making which is always
right this is an act of rhetoric it's
always an attempt to persuade people so
they're using the arguments that they
think are most accurate or the most
compelling in a historical moment so the
things that they say give us clues not
so much about what what's in their minds
but about the intellectual context of
the day so this is the approach I'm
taking to actually all the different
legal language that I'm looking at yeah
not so much than that I understand that
they're always working with this like
any kind of legal decision and legal
change isn't only a product of culture
it's also a product of precedent and the
the legal tradition I'm focusing on the
the cultural context and actually in a
slightly different set of cultural
context and we normally look at in
looking at technology and communication
we're gonna go backwards with my
question because I'm going back to the
birth of the nation okay right and I was
able to see birth of the nation with
live music with the like the pianist
right there and that you know it's like
you're talking about beforehand like the
crowd and mob and the kind of idea of
that experience of a crowd and when you
when I saw I mean it's you know you see
this movie and the MU the music is live
and that that experience that you have
as a crowd is different yeah right and
what that means in terms of how that
speech influences people and that's I
know is that a question
I think it's an observation
yeah and and you're hitting on a really
interesting point that I kind of gloss
over here but in the like up through
probably you know 1910 1912 1912 to 1915
I guess the better way to put it is the
beginning of this kind of inflection
point where control over the site of
exhibition is shifting so before 1912
there is a huge amount of exhibitor
control over these films they're
presenting their own music they have
people they have people creating music
and sometimes they'll have lecturers
sometimes they have performers sometimes
these short films are inter spliced with
vaudeville right and so these were
crowded raucous Affairs and actually
sometimes of the exhibitors or the
people in Owen the movie theater which
spliced together films they'd speed them
up do various different things and
around 1912 the studio start
distributing sheet music and saying here
this is the music that goes with this
film so they're trying to control a
little bit more that experience you're
talking about and you know control the
sets of meanings that are accrued to the
film through music as well as through
the visuals so but yeah I think these
sites of exhibition and are very
important I think that's part of what
the justices are responding to they have
an idea about what these places are and
the type of experience and that it's
raucous and body and this is not speech
at the beginning I mean we show that the
Gutenberg press as the technology of the
time in 1791 and then really around that
time there was another new technology
the broadsheet which was you know the
new fast way to get information out and
with each one of these technologies
there was always a kind of a panic of oh
it's being used in an incorrect way and
I would say that many of the founders of
long now were proponents of the new
technology that we now use is the
Internet and we all thought that
fundamentally that
the more we connected people the better
things would be and I think we're
finally crossing a new threshold we're
realizing that actually connecting
people with totally no filters and
there's no news rooms doing
fact-checking and any of that we have
crossed and and strangely a new set of
people are saying wow actually this is
we're crossing into the people are
yelling fire in the theater line of the
First Amendment right and so that
argument seems to have been the fire in
the theater argument always gets made
with every new technology and I'm just
curious as to what you think of where
we're at with this one and where we may
be at with the next ones whether it's
generative speech from from computers
and and if we just need to spend our
time getting used to technologies and
and or and kind of call it truce during
those times as we get used to them or if
we actually need to change the law and
say you can't yell fire in the theatre
yeah so that's a really good and really
complicated question and in general I'd
like to call on the room to respond but
I'd also I want to say I think that
there's a couple things in there which
is one of the problems that you know I
think a lot of us are having with you
know the one of the problems that we're
having are the disillusionment we're
having with the internet right now right
is it didn't turn out as this kind of
Enlightenment project it's turned out to
be a hotbed of rumor and falsities and
things like that which has to do with
the specific ideas and content where I
would be interested in thinking about
the fire in a theater question is really
if we're thinking about when is the mode
of communication on the Internet
something that might cross over into
action or conduct and is that action or
conduct when might that action or
conduct be considered expression when is
it considered something that is just
brute action or whatever and how we
might think through that so we can think
through any examples where some of this
does seem to be more material or to be
somewhat
different in its mode of communication
or in its form that would be really
wonderful and useful and does anybody
else have anything to say because this
is a thing okay we have a question our
question is in the age of live-streaming
of events and Facebook live streaming
live streaming on multiple different
platforms do you consider or would you
consider that to be protected speech if
so should it be regulated and if so who
should be in charge of regulating that
speech should it be the platform's
themselves should they be government
regulation mm-hmm so this is kind of
like a doctrine question so I think
there's some lawyers in the room that
could maybe field the actual doctrine a
little bit better is this are you the
lawyer in the room that can feel the
doctrine ha ha do you can you answer
that you answer a little bit about it
because you know are we gonna recognize
the difference between an individual
live streaming a murderer say in
Cleveland ok
versus a protestor live streaming police
brutality at Standing Rock yeah I mean I
think there are I think the public would
recognize that there's a difference in
those two mediums like most the content
of those two but then who would be who
should be responsible for determining
what the public has access to and how
and you know are we willing to are we
going to recognize that as speech and
then I mean there are so many questions
that kind of process we recognize that
as speech you know if we're gonna make
some kind of like blanket statement like
all live streaming is speech because
it's just merely you know the
transmission over a distance of
something that I'm saying or doing which
I don't know that we would do that's a
question for the lawyers then we're
saying there can be no rules no rules
from the government Facebook can
implement its own regulations of that
right if we if we're saying this is all
pure free speech Facebook can have any
kind of rule it wants about that because
that's not covered by
the first amendment but a California
can't create a law saying you know any
kind of live-streaming should be subject
to a five-second delay or whatever kind
of thing is that kind of where you're
going well I I'm putting it out there
for people to think about that because I
think that there's definitely a public
push if you want to regulate people's
access because we don't like the the
platform's themselves don't want to be
seen as propagating violence mm-hmm
but at the same time it's very it's a
very difficult and nuanced question
because who should be doing the judging
about what you know what the public sees
and what the public doesn't see and when
do platforms want to be speakers and
when do they want to be mere platforms
or conduits which is a really
interesting question like Facebook
doesn't want to be a speaker right or
Facebook doesn't want to take on that
kind of role there's another dimension
that actually between both these
comments that brings together maybe part
of the other discussion we're going from
a broadcast era into a narrowcast year
so the crowded theater may not be very
crowded mm-hmm maybe a very insightful
kind of speech we actually there's a
there's a case right now about a
gentleman who's currently president who
incited people in this crowd without
public broadcasting so so you know it's
interesting because you talk about the
mass yeah and and we're now into the
Narrows in an interesting interesting
way yeah I mean following up on Xander's
question there's another thing which I
think has happened with the internet
maybe before that but very much with the
Internet and that is the anonymity of
speech it's one thing to say you don't
have freedom to say that if I don't know
who you are I can't stop that and so one
of the real sort of complex problems of
the Internet is that as anonymity real
or assumed seems to free people to do
things and say things they wouldn't
otherwise say and there's actually
almost no enforceability yeah and so you
could
Hey well that's not allowed but how do
you stop it unless you try to control
the broadcast media who very
aggressively try to say hey we're just
the broadcast media we're just the pipe
yeah so there's an accountability angle
yeah and and right broadcasting is in
the media where that's happening so much
yeah sort of going off of these
questions on what do you think are the
implications of these types of these
forms of communication being protected
in a free speech so let's say computer
code and other me produce
recommendations are protected what are
the major concerns is it that let's say
what the Facebook newsfeed is that the
news stories are they if they're
protected in a free speech is that
necessarily a bad thing how do we
protect against that is it just really
just a case of like what is an exception
versus not yeah so what are the
implications and what what are the major
concerns about this I mean this is
really interesting to me I'm interested
in a kind of definitional way like what
do we think you know speech is how are
we defining it at this moment so I have
kind of this very a very in a sense of
abstract kind of definitional interest
in I just find these questions kind of
interesting but at the same time I'm
very interested in I am very interested
in this question of what what the
interests are and what what is gained
and what is lost and so when we think
about things like the questions about
algorithms some people who would like to
argue that the output of algorithms are
speech want to do so so that their
platform cannot be regulated that would
be Google right they want to say that
their search results are our speech so
that we can't make any rules saying well
you can't put add results or you have to
filter them you know change your filter
for some kind of social reason and so at
times there we you know thinking about
what who wants these things and why is
one of the things I'm trying to grapple
with in thinking through these kind of
definitional questions it's not only
what are the technologies and how are we
understanding them how are
technology and culture mixing in these
moments but what are the actual kind of
implications in the world and you know
that's one I know there are many others
I'm sure I don't know so if somebody out
there has any answers to any of these
questions or be posed raise your head I
want to jump for a quick aside put this
current talk in the context of kind of a
larger thing you're working on because
you're you're in the midst of the
beginnings of working on a book on this
right so you what you want to draw that
boundary as the larger thing you're
working on so yeah I'm I'm in the middle
of a book talking about the history of
the ways that new technologies have
shaped the way how justices are thinking
about what counts as speech and there
are a couple of primary trajectories
that I'm tracing and one of them is this
kind of ideas versus action trajectory
and the way that the proliferation of on
one hand film and visual other visual
media including billboards
advertisements and magazines and
newspapers and photojournalism
are changing the way and things like
psychology like I presented here are
changing the way that justices and other
people are thinking about communication
and how this shifts to enable us to have
things like con you know some kinds of
actions included within free speech law
and one thing I should have mentioned
and one of the reasons this is important
and one of the things I should have
mentioned about the Barnett case is this
case I think is an important precedent
or one of the key shifts that had to
happen before film could be included
within free speech which happened nine
years later but this is also a really
important precedent that gets us things
like or say lays the important
groundwork for saying flag-burning
speech and things like that draft card
burning things like this this is a
beginning of symbolic expression so
that's one trajectory and the other
trajectory is looking at how radio was
an early form of distributed speech in a
sense
it was really hard with the early radio
to think about who was a speaker raised
questions about who was a speaker and
could you have speech when there was not
one person I clearly easily identifiable
person responsible for the output and
also radio was always commercial as well
as opinion and that this laid the
groundwork some important groundwork for
later discussions of commercial speech
so in each case I'm kind of taking
something recent
like flag-burning commercial speech and
in fact Citizens United
and tracing it back and giving an
unusual genealogy of it and tying it to
early twentieth century technologies do
we have another we just I sort of want
to go back to first principles which is
the first principle the first amendment
is that Congress shall make no law so it
it it sort of says Congress shall not
censor this stuff but there's censorship
going on all the time the editors of
newspapers decide what's going on then
and so there's a it if we sort of think
about the the break between what we
don't want the government to do Congress
the states as opposed to what we think
might be appropriate for Google or
Facebook or live-streaming
it sort of goes back to a little bit to
the responsibility of educated citizens
to sort of figure out where they think
the if everything should be speech you
know oh yeah of course that speech and
of course that speech but the the
censorship and regulation of speech is
not only limited to Congress like it's
not so much a question this is true and
and there's one thing I would add here
right is this is a primary way we
interpret the First Amendment is this
kind of negative Liberty but in the
1930s there was actually a very strong
set of conversation saying that actually
what this meant was that the Congress
had to
actually kind of create this level
playing field and had to create
opportunities for people to engage in
speech and you find traces of that in
all kinds of radio regulation and in
some key First Amendment cases in the
early 1940s like ap versus u.s. the
judges say well it would be pretty crazy
to say that you know that the idea that
we couldn't restrict speech meant that
we couldn't block a merger or block
actually it wasn't a merger but is
anti-competitive practices so you have
some interesting interpretations of that
but yes yeah you're right all right well
that's gonna end our conversation on the
mic but Jennifer's going to stick around
you're not allowed to leave until we
answer all these questions yes please it
will help me with my book yeah yeah
please please each other come up here
Jennifer's I expect to see a scrum up
here that's what we like is an active
discussion of course Jennifer thank you
so much I have a long now challenge coin
is a little token of our thanks
[Applause]
[Music]